this program is brought to you by Emory
University
we've won 11 national championships and
we've traditionally been very strong in
tennis and swimming and most recently
won a national championship in
volleyball
right now we have about 26 club sports
that's where they come into play we have
nearly 600 club sport athletes instead
of having administrators head coaches to
like really run like a program club
sports or teams and sports that like
compete different universities and
colleges but it's really run about a
student that's where they're awesome
it it's what you make of it so everyone
does it for anything for the love of the
sport there's no pressure on you to do
it but you can make of it what you want
I wanted to go to a good school and then
I happened to find out that Emery had an
office team rugby's like rugby's a big
sport like Ellen clubbing clubs sports
colleges because we want to hit like
kind of who I was as well as school that
was like academically successful played
albarn Georgia Tech Clemson UF Georgia
Tech UNC and UVA UGA vanderbilt florida
state university was on to ohio we went
to Pennsylvania last year old Division
one schools and we have an intramural
program that can reach as many as 6,000
people during the year and that's such a
great way to develop affinity with with
groups on campus and create some nice
camp spirit
if you wanted to do a sport ever you
wanted to do recreational activity you
have a way to do it here so it's less of
a spectator activity and more
participant activity
if there's any any sport that you've
been wanting to try any sport that you
did when you were five years old middle
school whatever I mean join a sport just
come here and do it
the preceding program is copyrighted by
Emory University